you have voiced a sense of hopelessness
about reaching the wou keys David fuller
verbal wisdom says he's focusing on
having this conversation without
triggering the immune response I want to
suggest that we take cues from Benjamin
Boyce especially in his recent episode
with the Union I don't know I'm not
familiar with that episode but obviously
we're familiar with Benjamin boys and
with David fuller rebel wisdom and that
was that's the question yeah let's put
it this way the experience of trying to
reach the truly woke is not a positive
one because even to the extent that you
can reach an individual it doesn't last
it's not durable because they return to
whatever milieu it is that caused the
locus in the first place there's undone
although there's maybe a little seed
planted Oh believe me I'm a big fan of
the planning the seed that can germinate
later but there's also a campaign to
eradicate those seeds socially the fact
though is maybe this is actually just
the point you were just making we have
started to hear often it comes in the
form of an apology which I must say I
don't think I need but people have
started to contact us and say I got it
wrong I thought it was just college
campuses I thought you were exaggerating
now I see right mhm
in the wake of the last three weeks yeah
and again I don't need an apology
especially if you're you know if you're
a big enough person to recognize that
you were wrong and actually say it to
somebody that you think you may have
discounted that's that's a big thing and
that's all that's necessary from my
perspective what what I would ask beyond
that is okay now that you've seen it
find your courage because you're gonna
need it right and with respect to the
woke it's not one level of woken us
right there are people who are Rescue
able and the fact is to the extent that
we start bringing people over to the
side of reason then we have greater
leverage to access people who are more
deeply ensconced and so I do think most
of the people involved in this movement
are not aware of what they have signed
up with yeah no I think that's right and
I found just just in the last couple of
days I had interactions with some people
who I know in a business relationship
with you know like a structural
integration therapist and a haircut or
haircut or hairdresser and someone else
I can't remember so people who I have
iterative relationships with I will see
them again I enjoy them very much but I
don't know them well they don't know me
well and it's easier especially for
women on average to just let the
conversation go and when someone says
something that you disagree with to to
not disagree especially right now right
especially given that we are all being
expected to adopt the new the new gods
and not doing so on my part with you
know these people who had already chosen
to interact with on the basis that they
are reasonable and honorable and not
completely ideological was still not the
easiest thing in the world but
absolutely a hundred percent worth doing
and I I'm I would say that everyone can
do at least that yeah everyone can do at
least that that when you when you hear
someone say something in what sounds
like need your support of say a movement
or an organization that you don't think
is what it appears giving a little nudge
in the direction of what you think can
be can be the thing necessary to change
people's minds and and just to open them
up to the possibility that what they've
been told isn't the full truth and maybe
not maybe
is not any of the truth in fact so what
I've said a number of times is that
there's actually a a thing you can train
yourself to do which is very rewarding
which is when you have an unbridgeable
gap figure out whether or not you can
cross it in other words there are some
gaps you probably can't cross but you
can practice the skill and the gaps you
can cross get bigger and bigger and it's
very rewarding when you get across them
so if we all took that approach we might
do much better
[Music]